-Our first guest tonight
is a United States Senator
from Vermont.
Please welcome back to the sho
Senator Bernie Sanders.
How are you, Senator?
-I'm great, Seth.
How are you?
-I'm very well.
Last time we had you here
was the day after inauguration
when you were the man who
launched a thousands memes
And I know you're a very
issue-oriented guy,
and I do appreciate the time
talking to you
about those issues.
But do you miss that your moment
of meme has died down a little
-Well, let me go into my pocke
and bring out my mittens here.
It's a bit warm, but --
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
You know what?
I think that's --
a lot of people,
when they had
their mitten moment,
they continue to push it.
They'd wear their mittens
into the summer.
But you just let it go.
You moved on.
-I moved on.
Now that it's 90 degrees
here in D.C., I said,
"What the hell?
No more mittens."
But you know...
-Now, I promise I'm gonna
talk about substantive issue
with you today,
but at the very end,
I do want to,
if you will indulge me,
ask about a few more memes
-[ Laughs ]
-But only when we're done
with the substance.
-All right.
Let's get to work.
-[ Laughs ]
So, there's a lot of focus
on how the early days
of the Biden presidency
have been progressive.
And the question
I have for you is,
do you think this is a permanent
move by the Democratic Party
or do you think it is temporar
based on the crisis
that we have lived through
this past year?
-I think it is both,
but mostly your first point.
I think the President
and his staff are smart.
And on issue after issue,
what they see
is that the American people,
and certainly people
who consider themselves
Democrats,
support a progressive agenda
So, if you are a good politician
and you look out there and say
"Hey, these ideas are popular.
People who vote for me
support them.
You know what? Might be
a good idea to do them."
And the second point, though
Seth, is the question you raise,
is the President -- I know thi
'cause I've talked to him --
has also looked around
this world, right now,
and understands that, in terms
of democracy in America,
whether we remain
a democratic society,
where we deal
with the terrible sufferin
of the working families
of our country,
who've been left behind,
whether we deal
with climate change,
that this is a moment
which requires bold,
big thinking and not
the same old, same old.
So I think that's where
the President is coming from
-It seems as though
the Republican Party
has struggled in trying
to frame President Biden
as this progressive firebrand.
And they're using
a lot of the attacks
they maybe had prepared for you,
had you been the nominee.
Is it interesting as you watch
them try to pin down a way
to criticize the Biden
presidency so far?
-It is.
And the reason they're havin
a hard time is that, you know,
on almost every issue
that the President
is moving forward on,
the American people and many
working-class Republicans
support what we are doing.
So if we say that, "In the midst
of an economic crisis,
which we are just
passing through now,
we're gonna put $2,000
in your pocket
because you may have
lost your job,
we're extending unemployment
or expanding healthcare,"
you know what?
Working-class Republicans,
not to mention Democrats, say,
"That's a good idea.
Thank you, Mr. President."
-One thing that we're noticing
and we've talked about
a fair amount on this show
is the Republican Party
continuing to choose to be close
to President Donald Trump
and their inability to move on
and certainly as evidenced
by the fact that they vote
Liz Cheney
out of her leadership position
Now, you are not someone
who has much, if anything,
in common with Liz Cheney,
but are you surprised
at the speed in which the part
sort of kicked her aside?
-Seth, this is a huge issue.
I mean, it really is.
In my view, I think
that the political debate
in Washington now is not about
healthcare or taxes or climate
It really is -- and I say this
without exaggeration --
it is whether or not we remain
a Democratic society ruled -
governed by the rule of law.
What Liz Cheney's situatio
is about, as you've indicated,
she is a very,
very conservative Republican
She's a real
right-wing Republican.
But she made a mistake.
She actually understood
that Donald Trump lost
the election and Biden won
And she said,
"We had fair election.
Biden won.
Trump lost."
And for simply saying that
she was thrown out
of the leadership
of the Republican Party.
Because the line is, you know,
whatever the line may be,
is we are seeing a party
which is less of a party
and more of a cult
based around a big lie
that Trump won the election,
by the way, by a landslide
And when you go down that path
that there are Republicans
who have said exactly
what I'm saying,
you're going down the path
of authoritarianism
and undermining
our democratic society.
Very scary stuff.
-Much has been made
of how it does seem as thoug
this is a party, when we tal
about the Republican Party
in disarray,
and yet you have warned,
and I think that you are ver
cognizant of the fact
that you cannot underestimat
the futures
of the Republican Party,
not just in 2024 but in 2022
in the midterm elections.
How do you make sure that th
Democratic Party, at this point,
understands that the --
you know, this is a very
temporary moment, possibly
insofar as leadership?
-That's --
Look, I don't use the word
"disarray"
for the Republican Party.
I don't know
that they're in disarray.
I think what they are doin
and what their leadership
is about is rallying aroun
Donald Trump,
who is a pathological liar
who is an authoritarian,
who is a racist and a sexist
They see that
as the future of their party
That's not disarray.
That is where they choose to go.
And you're asking me,
"What's the antidote?
How do you deal with that?
And it is not easy.
It is not easy.
I think one way we do it,
among many others,
is to make sure that all people,
including working-class
Republicans,
understand that government
can work for them.
You don't have to, uh --
You know,
you don't have to be a racist.
You don't have to be a sexist.
That, in fact, government
can respond to your needs.
That's why we are working
so hard right now on creatin
millions of good-paying jobs
rebuilding our infrastructure,
roads and bridges, expanding
that to include education.
If you're
a working-class Republican
and you don't like Democrats
but suddenly you see
that your kid can now get
a good-quality education
at a cost you can afford,
you know what?
You're gonna say,
"Thank you, Democrats."
If you see
that you have healthcare
when you previously did not,
if your minimum wage goes up
if your community now has decent
water and bridges and roads,
you will, I think, begin t
understand that government
can work for all of us
and not just the few on top.
-I have a lot more to ask you.
We'll be right back with mor
from Senator Bernie Sanders.